we've heard a lot about what it feels
like to perform at the mothership
interviewing various comedians but you
also work there what is that experience
like it's like the coolest job ever you
feel what I'm saying I I have some jobs
but it just like feel like college you
know saying I a't never went to college
so kind of meeting all the big comedi
like that WM on the clock and like I
mean cuz being a du guy like that's a
big thing bro like working there is like
one of it's one of the best experiences
I've had like as a person you know what
I'm saying do you feel more connected to
the Kil Tony family or or the mothership
family or do that all blend into one it
all one family yeah it's all one family
you know what I'm saying it just got
different like you know saying like cous
and it's one it's one big ass